here's joe ross tenth career start
against the mets three and four with the
527 era so the mets have the laid off
man on and now francisco lindor who's
going through another rough patch all
for his last 11.
and ledore lifts one to deep center
field backhoes wall west on the track at
the wall it's out of here
francisco lindor with a two-run homer in
the midst of an instant two-nothing lead
goodbye 21-inning streak hello francisco
lindor his seventh home run of the year
and it's two-nothing new york well i
felt that he'd be able to catch up to
this guy's fastball both pitches in the
same spot so that breaks the ice for the
mets david peterson coming off his best
start of the year yes his last start is
very promising something to build on
good slider by peterson to strike out
schwarber and that's how peterson's day
begins soto betting 263 with eight
homers 28 runs batted in
swing and a miss and soto retired on an
upstairs fastball peterson's got a
couple of strikeouts so the woes
continue for mr soto
my goodness peterson has done a great
job putting away hitters with two strike
fastballs this year
that's two of the nationals nothing
right in there and guillerme knew it
joe ross second straight batter struck
out
and now four in a row since the home run
well good adjustment by joe ross this
happening you can see this ball located
down at the knees that's where he has to
live the effective good front hip sinker
there now the batter for the match is
mason williams the center fielder
upstairs another strikeout here's tomas
nito the catcher swaying in a miss
got a deadly slider going in the second
inning strikes off the side
six straight outs four on strikes that's
two of the nets nothing lendore hit a
two run home run to left center in the
first inning the first pitch on the way
and lendore lines it to right center
that's a base hit fielded by soto
peterson around third he'll score easily
as the throw goes to second and on at
first with an rbi single is francisco
lindori's driven in all three runs and
the mets have a three to nothing lead
well indoor now five for eight in his
career against joe ross and it's good to
see francisco lendore impacting a game
in a way that he really hasn't very much
for the match this year even as his bat
has come around lately we haven't really
seen him take over a game in the manner
that he is so far in this one the top of
the washington batting order david
peterson starts his second tour through
the batting order one two coming to
schwarber and he shows bunt and he bunts
the third strike foul
well the shift was on so he figured he'd
try and lay one down but tried to do it
with two strikes
about that was that just is that like a
third down punt well if he gets it down
it's an easy hit because the mets were
in the full shift but
he did not
oops fourth strike out for peterson and
now trey turner and the curve ball in
there strike three call
so peterson goes to his fourth pitch and
uses it to strike out trey turner after
falling behind 3-0 on the back door
how about that
two curves during the bat completely
caught turner off guard peterson had
thrown his curve 0.4 percent of the time
coming into the day so it's only natural
that turner wasn't looking for it
certainly wasn't looking for two in the
course of that at bat
peterson will work out of the stretch
with the runner at third
3-2 coming to bell
and it's grounded to short rat at
lindor and that retires the side so
peterson works around the wild pitches
keeps a three-nothing lead as we go to
the fourth in the seven inning game
mason williams struck out swinging first
time
swing and a miss
jason williams down for the second time
and for joe ross strikeout number five
first that bad he got him with the
slider this that bat
stuck with the sinker
great location good rotation also on
that sinker that'll bring in the number
eight hitter tomas nito
hart hit the other way josh to his left
pretty smooth it took him two steps to
get the ball out of his glove and joe
ross has the one two three inning we're
halfway through this seven inning game
here's robles who walked his first time
up harrison at second with two down
that's hit out to right field mckinney
chasing back a turnaround but he makes
the catch
good recovery by billy mckinney who got
spun in a circle and still made the play
after fourth three nothing new york top
of the fifth and david peterson is at
the plate to lead off the end that's
driven to the gap in right center field
and peterson's got his first big league
hit
and he will leg it to second base with a
double
so after getting on base and scoring a
run his first time up
now peterson has his first big league
knock and it's a double that's about as
broadly as i've ever seen him smile on a
baseball field hanging slider and
covered it nicely
and this is a bullet in the gap so they
show some confidence in peterson letting
him back and he comes through with his
first big league head and that is one
for the trophy case well the door has
driven in all three so here's another
chance for him two run homer in the
first rbi single in the third
and he drills this one a deep right
field forget that that is way out of
here into the second deck
francisco lindor have yourself a day
his second 2-1 homer of the afternoon
he's driven in all five in the midst of
a five-nothing lead number eight for
lindor his second of the game and he
crushed it
well another breaking ball here and he's
just all over it that was a no doubter
first multiple home run game is ahmed
12th of his career
a five rbi game for lindor and he has
had himself a field day in d.c
ten pitches three into the count
here it comes swinging a line drive left
center field this one headed for the gap
and it's gonna split the outfielders and
bang off the bullpen fence
smith picks it up with a 377 mark and
trey turner has doubled on the 11th
pitch of the at-bat
terrific at bat for turner
he has both nationals hits in this ball
game and that's his 12th double of the
season it looks like he knocked peterson
out of the game because luis rojas and
he's made the signal for the left-hander
aaron loop so he will come one out short
of qualifying for a win and luke will
come in to face juan soto
soto base it right field craig turner
speeding home
and juan soto gets the nats on the board
with his 29th rbi that'll close the book
on peterson well fortunately for juan
this slider ended up on the inner third
of the plate good job head down and
contact
able to just flip it over the second
baseman's head
easily scoring trey and the nationals
are on the board it's now the bets five
in the nationals one bottom of the
seventh inning last chance for the
nationals two out the met fans are
chanting josh harrison up with the
runner at third and two down one two
coming
he struck him out and the ball game is
over trevor may gets the final three
outs after a couple of base runners to
start the seventh as francisco lindor
puts on a show two home runs five driven
in and the mets take the opener of this
doubleheader five to one